the recent refugee crisis put a new spin  on visa liberalization for Turkish  citizens now part of the dual includes  Turkish authorities stemming the flow of  migrants to the EU well I've always  argued that all these things are  different and all these things have to  be negotiated separately and I'm not a  great supporter of the deal that has  been done by the EU with turkey over the  hill question of migration these are  made months to the visa liberalisation  dialogue which started in 2013 do not  sit well with mbps across the political  spectrum withholding visa liberalisation  is actually withholding activists and  journalists to travel MEP say they will  be monitoring the situation closely and  your progress report will be issued by  the European Commission in Adam